it feels like today is all about the
return of Liz truss are you glad to see
her back well she said you know uh
written this article and obviously wants
to provide a bit of her background
thinking actually in in many ways I
think uh what she has had to say
um you know will be things that people
knew about her all along um that she was
saying it when she was she was briefly
prime minister the most important thing
now is uh to get on with the things that
we've described and the current prime
minister has been very clear about his
priorities which you know really really
matter and getting inflation cut in half
will be a big priority growth in the
economy which is something which of
course Liz wanted to do herself
um reducing debt uh which we think is
very important um cutting the waiting
list in the NHS stopping the small boats
so all those priorities I think of
things the whole country will get behind
we'll definitely talk about some of the
priorities uh later but you know Liz
trust pictured on the front page of the
Sunday Telegraph saying I was brought
down by the left-wing economic
establishment what is the left-wing
economic establishment well people can
read their long article to to get her
version what about do you think the left
wing I mean she describes it doesn't she
she describes it in the article but what
I was going to say is and she says it
herself the most important thing that we
can do for the British people is make
sure that the economy is stable in
particular the inflation's falling and
she says it herself whatever the
intentions the markets weren't prepared
for it and I think she describes in the
article how
um and I think it's true you've got to
deal with the fundamentals first you've
got to reduce inflation which is the
biggest tax cut anybody really that's
not really what she's saying in the
article is it I mean she sounds to me
like she's basically saying she had the
right priorities and you talk about the
markets I mean I'm assuming that's what
she means by the left-wing economic
establishment you know the 45 billion
pound of unfunded tax cuts that crash
the pound and led to the bank of England
having to make emergency measures to
stop a run on Pension funds yeah I mean
in a sense you'd have to get her in the
studio and ask her I did read in the
article I noticed she said that they
hadn't prepared the ground for these big
tax changes and I think the truth is and
we know this what you've got to do first
is deal with the big sort of structural
issues that deal with inflation first
deal with the the debts you're on a
downward trajectory and and and then you
look towards tax cuts everyone wants a
lower tax economy uh we still have a low
tax economy than say Germany or France
or Italy but it's really important that
we uh that we deal with the big
fundamental issues halving inflation
first for example do you think it's a
bit deluded
for her to write to ask look I think
anybody who has served in public office
has a right to put across their
arguments that's what we do as
politicians right you you you say what
you believe and you put them across
she's going right to read it she's got
to make her own conclusion she's got a
right to put across her arguments but at
the same time if you're conservative MP
you know what's going to send a marginal
seat but to be completely honest right
now pretty much all concept of seats are
marginal ones
he's going to be reading this with your
head and your hands aren't you all it's
doing is reminding people of the
shortest serving prime minister who not
only crashed the pound but she crashed
your poll ratings as well well as I say
people can read it and come to their own
conclusions and I mean yes
sort of you're sort of asking me in a
sense what I think about it and actually
I want to make sure that we we have a
really stable economic basis for this
country so things like what do you think
of the actual Liz trust article because
you're asked answering a slightly
different question there right yeah well
I was going to say what we do know is
what happened when we followed that
route without having laid the groundwork
so I completely agree with Liz's
instinct to have a lower tax economy
what we also know is if you do that
before you've dealt with inflation and
dealt with the debt then you end up in
in difficulty you can't get the growth
out of nowhere so I mean but look I I
think the main thing for people to know
is Rishi sunx come in he's removed that
premium that we saw because the markets
didn't like what was going on back then
and and entirely remove the additional
premium that was being applied to our
essentially our mortgage rates so we're
back to where we we should be and he's
getting on with the the difficult the
difficult job of in a world where
Putin's invaded uh a country a
neighboring country and inflation has
therefore gone up he's gone on with a
difficult job of dealing with those
things so I think rather than looking
back and I know your tempting meters
will give a running commentary I'm not
just looking several months ago I'm not
just looking back I mean part of the
reason that I think it is important to
talk about Liz trance is that you know
there's been a lot of briefings from her
allies to say look she wants to make a
return to politics and she said it in
her article herself that you know in the
coming months she's going to be putting
out her vision some people say that look
she's waiting in the wing she's ready to
have another crack at it I mean would
you serve on a list Shadow cabinet well
look first of all I am focused on Rishi
sunak making sure that we win the next
election by sorting out these very
difficult problems and this is the thing
which I think is often missed in this
discussion the way this is framed often
you think these problems that we're only
facing the United Kingdom but actually
if you look almost everywhere else
they're not they're not only United the
same issues we are the only G7 economy
with a smaller economy than a
pre-pandemic if you look at the ifs
forecast we are bottom of the chart so
one of these things where in part
depends which stat you want to look at
from watch period so for example last
year we probably had according to the
IMF and the oecd the fastest growing
economy in 2022 in the G7 probably in in
2021 as well the fastest growing now
this year very much right well we we had
we had a rapid contraction but then of
course we came out of the of covid first
because we of the lockdown first because
we had the uh the vaccine which we
managed to develop it still has a
smaller so so what I mean so what I'm
trying to say is is you end up in a
situation where it depends which year
you look at to see what the bounce back
is one of the interesting things I
didn't see much reported from last
week's re-projection uh which as you say
rightly showed a a a more negative
position this year showed a more
positive position next year but my main
point is you know Putin involved invades
Ukraine inflation goes Sky High because
of energy prices this government
actually under this trust as it happens
but pushed through by Rishi uh sunak has
paid for about a third of people's
energy bills to try and help people
through these difficult times and we're
still doing that so people probably
don't realize when they look at this
it's got a high energy bills that the
taxpayer the government has stepped in
is paying a third of that now of course
that's going to have a big hit on any
economy but the point is you know
rishi's said it first of all deal with
that inflation don't feed that inflation
and then make sure you're growing the
economy and make sure you're reducing
the debt cutting the NHS waiting list
that's our priority let's talk a bit
about energy bills uh shall we because
you know British gas hit the headlines
in the last few weeks because of and
expose by the times which shows what is
happening to people when companies come
in and they forcibly install prepayment
meters which effectively means if you
don't put enough money in then your
energy gets cut off I know there was
this really moving story an undercover
story where there's a family with the
kids clothes on the radiators there was
a note on the door one of the doors to
the girls bedroom saying no boys allowed
apart from Daddy and they went in when
that family went out and they forcibly
installed a prepayment meter what are
you going to do about it well first of
all it's absolutely disgraceful we've
already hauled in the boss of British
gas made absolutely clear he accepts
that they've got it completely wrong I
also think that the regulator this is
off gem I've had the wall pulled over
their eyes actually because I had
already made clear to them that they
needed to be making sure that the energy
providers weren't carrying out this sort
of outrageous behavior I mean literally
evolves as you described invading
somebody's home and forcibly changing
the meter to a prepayment meter that's
not right at all and unfortunately what
the regulator was doing was going back
to the Energy company and saying are you
following all the rules in the engine oh
yeah yeah don't worry that's not the way
to do this I've required a plan for this
Tuesday from the energy companies and
from left off gem which needs to include
the regulator going direct to the end
consumer and the end consumer being able
to report these things direct to them
these kind of abuses are not on I've
called for all of the energy companies
to prevent to stop this process as a
British guests have and others like OVO
had stopped it some time ago and I want
to make sure that this does not occur in
Britain in modern Britain today it's
absolutely disgraceful no one should
have their home invaded like that it's
interesting you mentioned the regulator
there 33 000 complaints to often about
prepayment meters last year are they fit
for purpose well I look I I want to I
want to make clear that off gem needs to
raise their game on this it cannot be
acceptable simply to take the assurances
of the electricity companies or the the
power companies uh when they when when
we know that these abuses have been
taking place even before that Times
article I had set out the energy
companies and off gem that I had serious
concerns and that's before we saw this
undercover investigation and look we
have laws that prevent people from being
uh cut off from their electricity
there's no point me and the government
paying a third of the bill on behalf of
taxpayers so every every homeowner it's
getting about a third of their bill paid
this year because of these Sky High
Energy prices only to have the energy
companies come in and undermine that
effort so we're trying to provide energy
security for every household and
businesses in this country and we will
not have the system undermined like this
is have you done enough as well because
you talk a lot about you know how you
stepped in blah blah but you've only
just done this pretty recently this is
not a new practice this was going online
share as well wasn't it why have you not
acted sooner yeah well I've only been of
course business and Energy Secretary for
about three months yeah
but prior to that I was going to say
we've never had a situation in this
country where the state has been
involved in helping to pay People's
Energy bills about a third of your
energy bills being paid yeah but this
I'm not talking about this I'm talking
about the practice of prepayment the the
two things are connected the reason why
we're doing that and the reason why
there's been a big increase in in this
uh I would say abuse of people's homes
people being invaded to have their their
meter change is because of the high
energy costs so of course naturally this
is not an issue that was very high on
the agenda until Putin invaded Ukraine
uh and he created this spike in NG
prices so you know this has now been uh
uncovered and we are taking pretty Swift
action you'll you'll you say you're
taking Swift action um you've called in
British gas given him and talking to
you're right into the energy companies
to give them a talking to you is there
anything you're doing other other than
basically giving people talking to why
not have total ban well people people
could lose their licenses ultimately and
the reason you wouldn't want a total ban
is having to give you one simple example
my sum 21 uh lives in a in a flat in
London which she he shares um it's
actually very convenient for them to
have a prepayment me so it you know
there are some there are situations
where you want to be able to have that
kind of flexibility so I don't think we
should be banning all prepayments no but
would you ban anyone switching to a
prepayment meet without permission well
first of all there is a legal process
that has to be gone through I'm not
talking about the legal process I
understand there's various Hoops you
have to jump through but should you have
a total ban on people having a
prepayment meter if they don't want one
so well I was going to say the legal
part of the process is important because
this can't happen without a court saying
yes you can do this so I have a bit
Court's been doing it so the point isn't
they've just been signing them through
so as I was going to say the rest of
that is I think there's also a very
legitimate question about why thousands
of these have been being waved through
that is supposed to be the the check on
the system and and to answer your
question more fully obviously people
need to pay their bills and so there has
to be a backstop of look what happens
there does need to be a last case
scenario if someone can't pay that but
of course ultimately if you don't pay
your bills and people will have taken to
court that's the system we live under
right but I think ultimately there's a
legitimate question to ask about why
thousands of these warrants have been
waved through without a proper consider
consideration on an individual basis so
I think there's plenty that's gone wrong
here and I'm absolutely going to fix it
okay
um the Sunday Times today says that
Rishi sunac is planning some tough new
immigration laws that in their words
would take Britain to the boundaries of
international law and now Sky News
understands the PM is looking at Banning
people who arrive in the UK on small
boats from appealing
um is that true well so first of all
when you read those kind of headlines
lines it makes it sound like we're
talking about all forms of immigration
including refugees I have refugees
living in my own house and ukrainians
through ukrainians and their dog living
my own house this com this country and
this government has been incredibly open
and generous to genuine refugees what we
can't have are boats arriving here with
illegal uh gangs and gang Masters uh
trafficking people trafficking people
here and to be impotent in in return and
so arishi is absolutely right to apply
the full force of the law to stop this
illegal trade in human misery and I
think he's absolutely right to pursue
that and I think he's right to make sure
that we can change the law something by
the way labor vote against that every
single opportunity so the question they
don't want to stop the small boats and
we do the question is is the PM looking
at Banning people arriving on small
boats from appealing against deportation
so I I think the direction here I I
hadn't seen that specific story but the
direction here is quite straightforward
if you come here via an illegal route so
you come here to claim Asylum and you
know in the first place the way you're
getting here is not legal you haven't
got an airplane you haven't got a
commercial service you've just been
trafficked illegally then if you come
here by that route then you you
shouldn't get uh rights and that I think
is quite amazing yeah right you
shouldn't you shouldn't get rights if
you're brought if you if you consent and
you come here through illegal route what
we must have is a situation where people
can come here legally and claim Asylum
but not illegally yeah but the point is
you can't cut illegally to claim it can
you unless you are from people with
specific people who come here from
Ukraine from people come here from
Afghanistan people come here all the
time and legally claim Asylum when they
get here so the important thing is there
haven't been people traffic so to get
here they bought a ticket to get here
people trafficked and people are paying
for that trip by the way huge amounts of
money to the gang Masters it's not the
getting here free it's not them coming
here by that route
for people to come here and claim a sign
legally given you have to claim asylum
in the first safe country you pass
through
um to get here which which also calls
into question why it is that that hasn't
already happened before people end up
that's a different debate people traffic
I'm just questioning because they could
always play from legal routes for people
from countries other than those well all
I'd say is I don't think there's a
country with a bigger heart when it
comes to taking people in to say
including as it happens in my own home
bringing refugees here but you've got to
have that through legal Roots uh now
next week we're going to see nurses and
ambulance workers walk out in what will
be the biggest ever NHS strike will that
put lives at risk I'm concerned that it
does if you have a situation which is
what has been happening so far where you
don't have cooperation between the
backup Services typically the Army and
uh and the people who are striking so
we've seen a situation where the Royal
College of Nursing have very responsibly
before the strikes taken place case told
the employer of the NHS this is where
we're going to be striking and they're
able to put the emergency cover in place
unfortunately we've been seeing a
situation with the ambulance
unions where they refuse to provide that
information that leaves the Army who are
driving the backups here in a very
difficult position a postcode Lottery if
it comes to having a heart attack or a
stroke when there's a strike on we
cannot have that situation and that's
why I'm introducing laws for minimum
safety levels you um with some waves of
strike action right and one of the very
first unions to strike were the rail
workers you were a transport secretary
it feels to me like some people are I
guess blaming you really for the lack of
resolution
um here's Mark Harper this is the
current transport secretary and he has
said what I've tried to do since I got
this job was to I met the unions I've
tried to change the tone of the
conversation so that we're coming across
as more reasonable I mean I'm pretty
sure he's having a dig at you there
because she didn't meet the unions he's
implying that you didn't come across as
reasonable well absolutely certain it's
not because Mark and I talk about it and
we we get on very well so I don't think
that's his case at all and actually
interestingly do you regret your tone
that you adopted no look let me just
answer the question interestingly the
union said if you just let us talk to
you directly rather than talking to the
employers who by the way are the people
who need to resolve this then this whole
thing could be over they've now had
months and actually by the way two
transport secretaries since me uh where
they have had those discussions and
they've carried on striking so the whole
thing was uh you know uh you know a
screen that they were putting up to sort
of pretend that was the reason why they
needed to strike I might say though if
you if you'd engage with the unions and
the legitimate concerns people had about
pay and inflation much earlier then we
wouldn't be in this situation now where
it feels like both sides are totally
entrenched and the possibility of
resolution across all sectors well
that's very hard to see first of all I
did meet with them it was during covert
a lot of the time but I did meet with uh
LinkedIn uh covid online I've got no
objection to I mean I think it's a good
idea to meet and speak the simple point
I was making is the dispute is one which
is between the unions and their
employers and they're the only people
who can resolve it and I really want to
see it results let's just say this I
really want to see it resolved you know
um we've got it's incredibly sad that
some people who are the least well-off
are being hurt the most by for example
the train strikes where somebody maybe
is a hospital Porter a cleaner who
physically has to go to the job can't
work from home those are the people who
are being hurt so I think the quicker
this is resolved the better and I very
much hope that you know employers and
unions will get around the table and if
ministers can help great all the
evidence is it you know that not been
the the show changes so far now I won't
forgive myself if I didn't ask you about
this in the interview
on a very different note just talking
about your social media presence I just
want to have a look at something
now leveling up will be defined by
action and that's exactly what this
government is doing today hi can I get a
fat white please we're currently
inflation is about 10 I know what you're
thinking is he going to eat all of that
by himself
what if I told you this cake is actually
totally guilt-free
there has been a explosion of what I
would describe as kind of cheesy
government social media videos that I am
blaming you for for starting them off
what is going on they're guilty well
look I just think we can spend our time
like talking to the Westminster inside a
bubble actually if you send a regular
tweet that's what you do everyone will
get very excited
um or I've certainly found
um that if you produce videos which are
like more interesting I did one with
Michael Portillo uh about Great British
Railways uh I've done others with sort
of former uh uh people from for example
from Top Gear and actually you can cut
through you have millions do you think
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
trying to get in on your accent they are
yeah I've got to be honest I think
they're following might either but I
just think you know in the modern world
if you want to actually talk to the
country at large then you need to get
out there I you didn't show it there but
I also am on Tick Tock and other places
because you just get to the people who
you might want to engage with me
beauty of social media another we're out
of time but another photo that did go
variable viral was this one
um put on your Twitter accounts there
you are with Boris Johnson and as if I'm
magic
he's gone
it was a complete screw-up uh somebody
at that time which was I think 18 months
two years ago had screwed around with
the picture actually somebody with a
pixel phone which uh does that I
accidentally it was picked out the file
and sent not deliberately I love Boris
Johnson I enjoyed working with them
nobody wants to do that are you going to
go around there brushing list
actually I actually went to see the day
that went out I took it down as soon as
I found out uh what happened I actually
went to see um Boris and I said to him
let's take a photo and I'm going to like
tweet it saying there's no air brushing
him out this one or something like you
know but uh do you say yes we call the
photo but I didn't post it in the end
but it was a complete scrub not
deliberate at all okay thank you very
much